après la tempête de ces derniers jours
la bretagne ou panse encore ses plaies
sur son réseau électrique à ce jour près
de 300 foyers sont encore privés de
courant quinze mille agents edf étaient
mobilisés ce week-end pour intervenir
sur le réseau chantier particulièrement
important en ille et vilaine à sa jamais
hancock ou devrait intervenir
aujourd'hui un hélicoptère christophe
amouroux et philippe guillemot près de
80 agents plus une quarantaine de
militaires réparer la ligne à très haute
tension qui passe au nord de
l'ille-et-vilaine fait partie des
priorités d'edf plier couchés par le
vent
5 pylônes ont été touchées par la
tempête du 26 décembre
depuis le courant ne passe plus et les
équipes se relaient pour mettre sur pied
une ligne de secours
cette véritable autoroute électrique
constitue un des maillons importants du
réseau à l'échelle régionale et même
nationale
tant que nous n'avons pas rétabli cette
liaison au niveau de la bretagne
nous pouvons pas sécuriser
l'alimentation de la bretagne
puisqu'elle repose pratiquement
uniquement sur la production de
coordonnées et sur l'énergie qui est
acheminée depuis les centrales
nucléaires de la loire le chantier
s'étend sur plusieurs kilomètres
dans un premier temps il a fallu
acheminer est monté de nouveaux
portiques
il faut maintenant procéder au levage
des structures et dans certains endroits
la grue ne passera pas on est en train
de faire venir un puma de notre service
des travaux héliportés qui est basée à
salon de provence le cumin va se
substituer à la grue qui est derrière
moi pour poser les supports partout on
n'a pas pu accéder à la cellule de crise
on croise les doigts pour que la météo
reste favorable